the the weeds and the of this
application was difficult to predict it
depends on the markets and on all these
aspects that for for me I did not know
the main goal was not to develop a
sensor but when we found this effect
then the context was also that at that
time similar sensors were already in
preparation for the application in our
test drives I was always wondering why
do why do the planets orbit around the
Sun before people came to me oh it is
used in iPod mp3 players so I didn't
know about that so this is a very
important application I think because
these players are used everywhere
there's a huge application but of course
at some point probably there will be no
more improvement everything has physical
limits because it allows the application
of GMR first so are these the extension
of the Alex technology to mobile
electronics iPods awesome and also
medical applications I have seen
recently now if you know giamatti
encephalopathy do with the detection of
the magnetic field
and it's also nice to get some applause
that's always nice you are confirmed
that you know this is was the right way
to do something and we have arrived at
something so many things to find to
discover this is a good part of physics
you